the uh shadow leveling up secretary lisa
nandy is with us now your thoughts on
those comments first of all i mean
increasingly it feels to me that the
conservative party isn't just out of
touch with the reality of what's
happening in communities across this
country but they're living on another
planet we've got at the moment a crisis
that is engulfing families and
businesses across the country record
inflation it's not that people aren't
budgeting properly it's that they simply
cannot afford the basics and that is a
damning indictment of 12 years of
conservative government i've got a food
bank in wigan which you'll be familiar
with kay the brick which is now giving
out cold boxes because families can't
actually afford to cook the food that
they were being given these are families
who in many instances have two parents
who are both in work and yet they can't
afford to feed their kids we've got to
get help to people now we've got to get
money back into people's pockets and
most of all we've got to stop with this
sort of patronising rubbish that this is
somehow the fault of families who've
seen their incomes drop dramatically in
the last few months anderson is a former
minor he says his his comments have been
taken out of context and what he was
saying is that people can't cook
properly that they're not aware of how
to cook from scratch so as a result
that's why they go to the food bank well
people go to the food bank because they
don't have enough money
and they can't afford the basics
increasingly now in this country what
we've got is a lot of families who are
working harder than ever before you know
i i remember my parents working pretty
hard when i was growing up but now
you've got families that have two or
three jobs and are working on shifts
around the clock struggling with child
care costs struggling with energy bills
struggling with food prices struggling
with rent and mortgage payments it is a
perfect storm and at the time when they
most need help not only is it not
forthcoming from the government but
we've also got tax hikes on the way that
just isn't good enough we need an
emergency budget from this government
and we need to stop this sort of
patronizing rubbish about this being the
fault of people who are working harder
than ever before but shadow secretary
said there is no magic money tree where
are they going to get the money from
well we could put an uh windfall tax on
the oil and gas prices only gets two
billion pounds doesn't it but but they
made record profits and surely the
principle that those with the broader
shoulders should bear the greatest
burden at times of national crisis has
to apply the government is backing those
record profits over families in this
country who are struggling we could get
up to 600 pounds back into people's
pockets
and we could we could do more than that
we could cancel the national insurance
rise and we could start to invest in
this country again only this morning
we've released figures that show that in
england every region stands to lose out
because the money that used to come back
to us through the european union has
been cut by this government and it's
cost our english regions to the tune of
a billion pounds that just simply is
unacceptable we've got to get this
economy moving we've got to get growth
back into the economy we're forecast to
have the slowest growth rate of any of
the g7 countries next year and that is a
direct consequence of a government that
doesn't back its own people but even by
the by labour's figures two billion
pounds would be raised by a windfall tax
which would be about 600 pounds per
household that that's nowhere near
enough every pound matters at the moment
the people that lee anderson was talking
about in such condescending terms
yesterday are people who are getting to
the end of the week opening the food
cupboard and finding that there's
nothing to get them through the weekend
i think we've got to get money back into
people's pockets right now and up to 600
pounds would be a good start cancelling
the national insurance rise as i said
but also investing in things like
retrofitting homes which almost every
major business leader now says is a
no-brainer to reduce energy bills if we
started investing in people in this
country
we could see real action well
we had a period of record low interest
rates and during that time we were
urging the government to use that moment
to invest this is not just about
spending money people don't have a lot
of money and we've got to spend every
penny wisely but we it's about investing
in people so that we get growth back
into the economy so that people don't
have to pay such high taxes and can
afford where would the money come from
retrofitting property well let me give
you an example recently the government
just casually the chancellor with one
stroke of a pen wrote off over four
billion pounds in fraud uh that had been
committed during covid he just said
we're not going after that money he was
heavily criticized for doing so by
select committees in parliament by
major business leaders by the labour
party as well
surely we should be using every penny at
our disposal to get help to people now
and start investing in our economy i'm
just hearing as i'm talking to you in my
ear that the finland president has said
that they do want to join nato thoughts
on that
well i i mean i'm a big supporter of
nato i think it's been an incredibly
important alliance and i think what
you're seeing at the moment is the
actions of president putin in russia are
bringing the western world much closer
together
and a determination to stand together in
a way that we haven't seen for a long
time it was only a few years ago that we
had president trump in the united states
attacking nato and attacking the
contribution that european countries
were making you've had endless
squabbling between our government and
the governments across the european
union and now i think we're starting to
see us come together and stand together
in the face of russian aggression i
think that's a very good thing and with
your former foreign secretary hat on
though do you not feel that potentially
it could put finland in in a
more difficult position rather an unsafe
position rather than the one they're in
at the moment which is one of neutrality
well i think i think that countries
coming together and standing together is
really important it's a decision for
finland about whether they seek
membership of nato and then it will be a
decision for nato countries about
whether that's accepted but i think what
you are seeing is as a consequence
of increasing russian aggression that
increasingly countries feel that nato is
worth backing and supporting after many
years in which we've seen it under
attack and i think that's a profoundly
good thing what we're going to do about
the northern ireland protocol
i think we should seek a veterinary
agreement which would reduce a lot of
the barriers
borders that have been created and start
to reduce the tensions that have been
created around this as well i think we
should start with pragmatic practical
steps rather than this overblown
rhetoric that we've seen
in the last few years most people in
this country i think had thought that
brexit was done we've got to start
moving on and we've got to support
people on the island of ireland instead
what we've got is cons successive
foreign secretaries just ramping up the
rhetoric and the tensions and you know
in the last few days we've seen the
european union threaten to cancel the
trade deal because the foreign secretary
has threatened um to cancel elements of
the northern ireland protocol which her
prime minister negotiated which he
agreed which he said was a great deal
this just isn't good for anyone in this
country it's particularly bad for people
in northern ireland and it's about time
the government stopped mucking around
and behaving like children
and sorting it out should it be
scratched no i think we've got to make
it work and i think there are pragmatic
and practical measures that we can take
to make it work but it takes good will
on all sides i've been critical of this
coming there isn't well it could be
forthcoming i've been critical of the
european union at times for ramping up
the rhetoric but i think there's no
question that at the moment the big
problem is that we've got a government
that isn't serious about trying to find
a resolution to this i'm disappointed by
that i thought when liz trust was
appointed that it might herald the start
of a new approach it's not in anyone's
interest in this country to have an
ongoing war with our closest neighbours
we've got to calm down the rhetoric
start to cooperate not least because as
we've just been discussing we've got
serious russian aggression
war breaking out in in europe for the
first time in a long time and we just
simply can't afford any more of this
yeah um just before we let you go coming
up to wigan next week what can we expect
well i think you'll find a lot of people
who have had a very very tough time over
the last 12 years but don't complain
about it are getting on with things you
know what wigan's like people stick
together and they club together and one
of the great things that's happened over
the last 12 years in the toughest of
times with austerities or turbo charging
decline is that we've drawn on the
biggest asset that we've got which is
our community people are close they look
after one another and we've stepped up
to help people at the darkest of moments
i think you'll find a lot of that spirit
in wigan next week and um i know that
people are really looking forward to
having you oh that's lovely um we're
coming to see the brick as well of
course you just mentioned the bricks and
also going for um a drink a working
man's club oh well i look forward to my
invitation you can come yeah yeah i'll
have a pint and a half for the lady
thanks very much